I was the first comic to cancel my shows
I've chosen 2021 cancelled right now I
cancelled the tour after the cancel your
family tour I cannot believe I was
watching people debating there's people
doing shows tonight where DC improv zany
that shut it down shut it down some of
these people I know for a fact I've
money yeah they have money and they have
mansions go home you sick narcissists do
you really need approval from from
people that badly that you're willing to
go home and kill your grandmother cuz
you couldn't walk out of [ __ ] Zanies
is that where we're at now you're
willing to risk coughing on an old
person on the train and killing them
because you want to get some chuckles up
and Winnipeg shut it down please
it's a moral issue I understand if you
broke a lot of comics out they're broke
and they got to get every dollar I get
it I get it I'm not I'm not going at you
if you have to work if you choose to
work it is with it if you have the money
to not work right now as a comic don't
[ __ ] work don't bring your fans out
people were angry at me for Kanzi
Caroline's in a few other dates I'm
cancelled too early April listen [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] ain't worth comedy I love
comedy it's how I live my life it's the
the greatest thing I do is get up and
perform in front of people but I could
take some [ __ ] time off if the result
of me doing what I like to do kills
people you see see if me doing what I
want to do kills people then I'll I'll
take a breather take some time pod cam
asked make a video I don't know what to
tell you
but I love how reticent people were to
cancel they were like well I don't am I
supposed to not I people paid to see me
they paid to see me and get killed I was
first I called my agent last week I said
let's get let's take it out nobody's
even talking about coronavirus I was
like just cancel cancel cancel you by
next 2021 take a big take a red pen in
the big acts out acts done who these
[ __ ] that need to work what's wrong
with you it's a sick day times a
thousand what kind of [ __ ] are you
showing up to the office they told us we
don't have to show up to the office we
can go home
jerk-off a tea SpaghettiOs do that it's
not ruining everybody's fun you [ __ ]
wacko I get it if you need to work if
you don't have any money's gonna get bad
economically out there tip people tip
the postmates speakers people are gonna
get [ __ ] and then they're gonna come
for you if you're less [ __ ] keep the
guns keep the bars on the windows I'm
telling you I hope I'm wrong but it's
probably gonna get hairy and it's
probably gonna get tough anything could
get out of a city get out of the city I
can't I gotta be here broadcasting
during the end of the world but if you
can get out get out go to some ranch in
my time I don't know I can't tell you
how to live and if you're young and you
have immunity or you had it you got over
it this is the [ __ ] time to travel
the world plus he get out there get out
there take advantage of cheap flights go
eat that Wu hen bat sandwich go spit in
the strangers mouth you're young you can
take it I wish I was young I'm 35
and yes I'm in great shape and I do
triathlons but there's other people that
aren't and I don't want to put them at
risk but if I was 22 and in the shape I
never was I would be really rocking out
I would be jetting all over this globe
[ __ ] yeah
let me out of [ __ ] college and I'm
sorry I know it's very hard listen it's
I I my senior year of high school was
great was one of the funnest years of my
life I was nominated for homecoming king
I was extremely popular everybody loved
me blah blah blah that being said I know
that there's a lot of people now that
their senior year of high school or
college has been cut short
whether some of them are athletes and
they can't play their season their last
season some of them it might have been
tapped into skullenbones and now that's
not happening I'm very sorry and I know
it's very tough and a lot of lacrosse
players aren't gonna get to play and a
lot of people aren't gonna get to go to
the prom but I I say this and I say this
shut up
Italy's burning there are countries in
the world right now where they're
choosing who lives and who dies so sit
down with your privileged little
lacrosse rapists you've raised and sit
him down and say Tommy listen I know
you're upset that you can't play but let
me show you the country of Italy
remember when we went there two years
ago it's burning to the ground now
because they didn't follow these rules
so there are people that have worse
problems than you you little prick
you're gonna grow up and be fine you're
gonna grow up and be fine and you'll
remember this pandemic and you can tell
your kids how tough it was that you
didn't get to play your last season of
lacrosse which is a fake sport anyway
that doesn't go anywhere
there's no professional lacrosse way I
mean there's a few of teams in Long
Island like the Long Island lizards and
stuff like that but I mean that at that
point just I mean I would rather my kid
get Wuan and check the [ __ ] out not be
in the Long Island lizards